today we're going to be talking about
building a netflix clone with javascript
graphql and datasax astra
so
the nice thing about this workshop today
is that you don't really have to install
anything you can be in your browser
that's all i'm in is just in my browser
to be able to
to execute everything in this workshop
you have
github for the source code the exercises
and the slides
[Music]
you have git pod which gives you a
visual code like the the microsoft
visual code
um
environment
you have netlify to deploy and run and
host the things that we're going to be
doing today
and then you have the astra database
which is
allows you to have
graphql and graphql playground
and that connects directly to the
database and and you can see
it's pretty simple and it's an it's a
one of the native interfaces on our
astra database
so your mission should you choose to
accept it in the kind of old school
mission impossible
context is to
deploy a netflix clone to production
over a global cdn using
a new sql database with paging and
infinite scrolling good luck so for the
for the course of this we're gonna kind
of cheat a little bit because we'll have
a uh
a github repo that will give us some
guidance here uh and some setup
but uh i think this will be a fun
exercise
and it kind of shows you
how you can
use the graphql apis on top of cassandra
this is the basic setup is we have like
a reactive interface a react interface
on top of graphql and that graphql um
goes down into the database
and it's it's just another seamless api
that can be written on top of uh
cassandra in this case um the the
gateway itself
so when we talked to netflix uh about
our plans to include better apis so that
people didn't have to rewrite you know
i mean there's always a
capability of writing to the database
native database interface with like you
put in your dependencies and all of that
but um we wanted to meet developers
where they were and so we created an
open source gateway
and you can host this on top of your
existing cassandra cluster or you know
whatever cassandra based solution that
you have
and then
it's a native interface within astra and
so i'm going to go ahead and show you
that
after i give you just a little bit of
architectural background here so um well
why don't we just jump in
so
if we
go to this url and eric if you wouldn't
mind putting that into the environment
there
is the data stacks devs
app dev week 3 graphql
and
if you want to follow along that's great
all of this is
self-contained and there's a a live demo
that anya cubao
if you haven't seen some of her kind of
live coding exercises she's pretty
amazing she's just she blasts through
stuff and is very engaging
she did like a three hour version of a
similar exercise um with us
and this kind of takes some of that and
puts it into a shorter form so that you
can get it all done and you have an
example so if you wanted to do this
yourself and and wanted to have some
examples of of how to hook it all up uh
this is a
this this allows you to play with it a
little bit more
so
as we're starting
you can do it on your own computer
uh i like get pod because this allows
you to um
and and netlify just because it allows
you to have kind of just like a
persistence out in the cloud so you
don't have to worry about it you don't
have to pay for anything in the workshop
everything is free
and
you'll need a github account
and probably chrome or firefox in order
to do this
and netlify and astrodb
will be
worked through through the exercise so
no big deal
you can follow along it shouldn't be too
too bad there's some slides in here
there's the discord chat discord chat
but let's just jump in
so what we'll want to do is to start up
with going to astra so just go to
astra.datastax.com
and then you get to this screen
this will allow you to register and if
there's no credit card it's a free
developer account
and you can deploy databases and all
sorts of stuff and so i have a free
account i don't even use a paid account
which is kind of
handy because i can do any kind of proof
of concept or create whatever databases
i want
and it's a little bit different than
what you might normally expect from a
cassandra database because cassandra
typically like a netflix uses it this
way they have thousands of instances of
netflix that are persistent they're
there all the time they span it across
multiple availability zones and it's
it's basically you're on instances of
they use a lot of aws
um in our case uh what we've done is
we've seen that uh cloud native
applications and kind of serverless and
operations have been
more of a
a draw from from like the the ease of
use as well as elasticity as well as um
cost perspective and so what we've done
is we've created a cloud native
serverless version of cassandra which
hides any sort of infrastructure and all
you really pay for or even care about is
the throughput and the throughput you
pay for per million read requests per
million write requests and then you pay
a monthly cost for storage and it
operates on
aws gcp and
azure
and so let's just go ahead and create
our database in here
so let's kind of follow along with this
so i'm going to create a database in
astra
um
i'm going to get netflix workshop dbe
in here i'm going to put it in
australia east and azure so that's nice
and local
and then i'm going to make a netflix key
space to try to just give seed our
kind of seed our foundation here and
like i said all of this is free you
don't need to worry about any cost here
so let's go ahead and create this
database
and it'll just be just a minute for that
to to
get spun up this is just activating
right now and you can have any one of a
number of databases you don't have to
pay for database instances at all um
even if i were on a paid plan you just
paid for what consumption that you use
which is kind of handy
so
let's go on here there's it's pending
and so it'll take a couple of minutes
and then i'll receive an email let's see
it'll be
oh i i've done it a couple of times
today so i'm kind of
ready
restarting all of this
but oh it looks like it may be on mine
oh the region availability is online
never mind so it's still pending it
might just be another minute um
what i need to do now is create a
security token and so what i want to
create in here is that astra operates on
the principle of least privilege uh
being a good kind of like multi-tenant
system and so i'll go in here and i can
just go into manage organization
settings the nice thing here too i like
about this is that if i have a buddy
that i'm i'm working with and he or she
is is creating a database i can um
i can add them to my organization or
vice versa and we can work on the exact
same database and it's still a developer
account across us and so i have my own
personal organization
and i go in here
and i say i need to create a token and
so like it says and here if you're
following along you create a token with
database administrator
so i come in here and i did that today
and i have a database administrator so
what you do is you just say database
administrator and this gives you
specific access you can have a custom
role as well and you can give it
specific read write access and have a
service account and do all sorts of
stuff
this allows you to do things like create
a
private endpoint like a like a
private link type of endpoint
and that sort of thing and so if i
generate that token
i've already done that but let me just
generate another one just for fun
if i go in here
i can download that
and save that to my environment
and then let me get a new screen here
just for fun
and i'll i'll go
into my environment here and it looks
like it's active now
so this is my database id i'll go in
here
and
i have my
netflix key space
let's take a look at the health of this
and let's see if there's another
what's next on our checklist here
so i'll want to go into open graphql
playground and so i'll connect to my
database
so here's my
grafana display for my database um but i
need to go into graphql api you can
connect with a lot of different things
you can use spark with it and you can
use all these interfaces but one of the
native interfaces is graphql
and so i'm going to start a playground
to mess around in
and
what it'll ask me for is in the http
headers
there's a token under the covers
so that was the token that i created
here
so if i go on here and i use my headers
down here
is it
populate me
got my astra token right there
my database administrator token and i
come back here and what do i do next i
am in
the playground and i have that
and i want to create something so in
this case i'll copy this over i'll go to
my playground
and i'll create a table so my key space
name is what i already had and this is
to to to do the graphql schema
is netflix key space and the table name
that i'm using is reference list and
this is just the syntax to create a
table within that key space if not exist
true so it'll just be you know
a non-operation if
it happens to be there i have a
partition key
which is the label
and then clustering keys i have the
value and i'll sort that i'll store that
on disk
so
um
let's go ahead and create that with the
key that i have in there
so i've created that reference list
and
let's go ahead and see what we have next
insert some data so let's get some data
in here basically this reference list is
for genres so we have a bunch of movies
movie genres that we want to put in here
and like i said i mean this is really i
mean this is a simplified example of
what netflix does but it's true to form
in the sense that netflix stores every
piece of data that's not a kind of a cdn
um
optimized movie file or or picture file
in cassandra including account data you
know recommendations
where you last left off you know if you
are on your phone and you're on netflix
and then you started on your laptop once
you get home off of the train or
whatever
then um it'll start where you left off
and all of that data
is stored in in cassandra um so let me
copy this out i might have already done
that and i'll go to my graphql screen
and i'll write my query or mutation here
but i also need to put that in here too
so let me get that token again
and i'll
populate that so it knows
how to authenticate
and i'll get rid of that
and i'll add all this data
oh
i have some sort of problem here
oh that's right one step i missed
is that i want to put in change the key
space from system
to
netflix key space i've
it's trying to insert that into my
system key space and it's like what
so there we go so we have all of that in
there so we can add some some other data
if we want to
uh
let's see
so in terms of getting data so that's
that's you can see the basic syntax that
we have for inserting data into our
cluster
is just inserting and then the genre
uh is the label and the value is you
know what we have for that value
and
[Music]
let's go ahead and get all the genre
here
and then
we'll go ahead and see oops
wrong one i thought i
copied that never mind
so we can see that it's stored in the
database and just as a kind of a
interesting
exercise here
is that you can store it in
graphql
and if you have somebody who's more
familiar with cassandra like one of the
back-end cassandra engineers at netflix
you can let me do expand
that means that it goes horizontally
instead of like vertical columns so it
makes it easier to read is select star
from
netflix reference list
so you can see
it stores it in a way that you can
connect with um
the cassandra interface or the graphql
interface or a rest interface and it
really doesn't care it'll it's a native
interface into the database
um
so let's go back
what else do we need to do here i
suppose we need some movies
so let's create a movie schema and what
we're doing here let me bring it over to
the playground here under the graphql
schema
we have a movies by genre and what this
means is that my partition key is going
to be the genre so we're going to put a
bunch of movies in each genre into the
cluster the clustering keys are going to
be the year and the title of the movie
the year descending so the more recent
movies are going to be at the top or in
the front from a data perspective
that'll optimize that
and then we have our synop for each
movie we have the the title of the movie
as a clustering column and then the
synopsis duration
and then a thumbnail and it says text
and so we're really not storing the
actual thumbnail file in the database we
want this to be a cdn kind of replicated
thing
and so
let me get that up
there we go
so we'll i'll show you in just a minute
but let's create this table first
so that's done
we'll go back here
and we're gonna insert a handful of
movies so you know inception prometheus
aliens blade runners just some movies
that we might like to see in our
in our database here
so let's put those in the database
looks like they're there but let's go
double check
and we'll play with that a little bit so
we have
getting getting the movies out of there
and we can see that you know this is
just basic graphql
with the order by and all of that kind
of thing um one thing that we could do
and this is part of the kind of the
what our task is for today is how do we
do paging because you know you look at
netflix and everything doesn't load on
the screen at once
you you want to do that on demand as you
scroll or as you click the arrow and so
let's let's start with some sort of
paging built in here into our graphql
which we can implement in the backend as
well but just as an example
so we have a page size of two and what
that does is it gives us you know
two in a page and it gives us a page
state at the end which is kind of handy
because we can do something like this if
we go down a little bit further
if we have options page size 2 and then
put a page state in there
then
[Music]
it it keeps the cursor alive basically
or you know not cursor but you know what
i mean is it keeps it so that we can get
to the next page as we scroll for
instance in a ui setting
so if we do that these are our first two
um
you're descending and so we'll get what
is that aliens and uh
blade runner in the background and you
can see here too is that the thumbnail
is this
you know mp4 file that relates to i
think all of them or most of them are
are
set up correctly
to
to point to a movie file that has to do
with that
that movie
so
one thing that we can do as well is we
can download this data set hopefully
you're able to follow along if not
everything's laid out in this github
repo for you you can download the data
set i have it kind of baked into my my
back end here
is you can download the data set and
it's not very large but what it does is
it allows you to see
how you can let's go back in here we'll
load some data
and if it's up to like 40 megabytes you
can upload your data set in this ui i
cloned the repo in my local environment
and so it's in the data directory of
this and so it's just a csv file so if i
do that
it's going to tell me okay let's upload
this
and then it gives you a preview of
what's in the file with all of the
fields and the intended um
types
and so what i'll need to do is say the
only thing i really need to specify is
the partition key which in this case is
a genre
and so i can add clustering columns if i
want to but as soon as i have the
partition key it should be fine and
now i just need to tell it what table to
put it or the key space to put it in
which is a netflix key space
so it's it's uh importing now so what it
does is it triggers the job in the
background it takes about a minute or
something like that so it'll says that i
have my my workshop db created
um and
it'll in the background
do that let me see if i've got
everything caught up here so it's a
handy way to just kind of load some data
in the background and a number of if you
go on here there's a sample app gallery
that has a bunch of different apps and a
lot of those apps use that same
interface to just give you an idea
of how to mess around with a database
one thing that we added to today as a
matter of fact yesterday or today is the
ability to add another region so if i
wanted to to add a region
um
i can add one of the other regions in
azure and i can replicate over to that
region so if i have
uh
cassandra's always been able to do that
and that's one of the reasons why
netflix uses it
but
but now with the serverless model we
needed to to kind of have some specifics
around uh how to handle that when in a
cloud native environment um
so let's see is that
okay the load job started i think it's
going to take less than a minute it's a
pretty small file um
let's see where we're at now so
i should be able to get oh yeah it's
going through telling me what i need to
do with the
all of that and then we say what target
and then i should get some emails that
say that i can i can check that out and
then cql let me just see if i can do
that now
uh
started ah let me mess with it let me
see select let's do expand
on
[Music]
looks like it's done so we have like
suicide squad toy story
uh teenage ninja turtles too of course i
guess i don't know
um
so a bunch of different movies
loaded
and so
that's that's how we've kind of
bootstrapped the database for the
purposes of what we're trying to do here
so
what we want to do then is
in this repo
you may notice that there there's not
just data in this repo let's go ahead
and deploy to
netlify
so i'll connect to my github account so
that's why you need a github account is
that it's going to
um
you're going to give it some access so
that netlify can
deploy
this repo
and essentially fork that repo into your
own github account and then make that
into
yeah it's deploying now so it'll it'll
it'll um deploying that from if you look
in the bottom here my
my my roommate from college decided that
my computer was called the jeromatron
5000 so he just decided that so i
thought that would be an easy way if you
look at the bottom of this window
jerometron is uh
my handle and so it forked the repo into
my github repo and it's now deploying
into that repo
in in netlify and
so
it'll be just a minute for it to kind of
download
and then do some building
[Music]
and it's deploying
and and all of that and what it does is
is
it deploys from my
um
my own repo and and so what we need to
do is go to my repo that has been
configured here
and let me open that into a new window
oh wow it's doing that right now still
okay well i'll uh
i won't be impatient i'll let that kind
of finish
hopefully everybody's doing well
in the background there
um let me see if there's any questions
in the interface
thanks eric for answering questions in
here
um
like he says there's some
some discord stuff that that if you want
to join discord we have kind of a
continual persistent conversation in
there if you have any questions about
this
i'm kind of going through this
fairly quickly but hopefully it's not
too hard to keep up with this
um
site deploy in progress this is still
let me see where this is at
oh it's still
let's see if this is
this is trying to deploy still
um
it will take just a minute
and what we'll do is open git pod and
git pod is a nice environment and to to
do all of this in and
let me scroll up
and just show you
um
what else is in this repo so
you'll see that uh
there's the source
which has some basic stuff in there
there's like the components
like you have like the scroll bars and
a navbar and a card for each movie and
that sort of thing
and then you have an index.js
and it's fairly simple when when it
comes down to it
you can see in here there's like the
hero section
and this doesn't get movies on the
netfly functions and so if we go to the
get movies in the functions
um
[Music]
the
graphql is fairly straightforward right
so the query
so you have like this astrographql
endpoint which is in the environment
that we'll set
um and then all we're really doing is
what we did in the graphql playground
right so we have uh the movies by genre
and
we can get the page state and that's
what is coming out of the request
and we have the genre that's coming out
of the request and we have the page
state down here and the
to keep keep in the background um as
well as
the uh various values and then you know
just
what we do
on various responses
and we have the fetch
that gets it based on the token and the
token is the other thing that we need to
populate in here let's see if this is
completed
looks like it's done
so if we go into here
uh
this is my
fork
of the same thing and so i could come
into that and and deploy into git pod
but then it would deploy to get pod in
the data stacks to get devs repo and
that's probably not a good idea um
so let's go down
to back where we were
and this will deploy
in my own environment in get pod
where are we here
okay so this will be
using
the gerometron
repo and what this does is it sets up an
environment for me
it has the repo and it'll go into
a visual code visual source
sorry visual studio code
environment online
in my dedicated environment
and then i can configure some things to
make it all work together so this is
going to jump in
it has all of the information in here
and then it's doing all of the npm
initialized stuff
in here
and so we'll have that all set up
i'm going to add a new file in here as
it's doing that so
let me jump back into here
i'll verify that i'm in the environment
that's appropriate and that should be
fine
the other thing that i'd like to do
is make sure that i have an environment
so this sample environment
is let me uh
create a new
if you're familiar with like the npm
netflix stuff you just need an
environment to to put some of the
variables that you need in there
um so for example if i want to do this
and i'll get rid of this
and so
what i need here
is
my token
that i've gotten where is that okay
there's my token
put that guy in here
and then my endpoint
and
if i go to connect in here i'll scroll
down
to where it says write data
and it gives me the endpoint in there
with the netflix key space already built
in so i'll go in here i'll go to connect
graphql
and what's interesting too just as an
aside is there's also a document api and
that document api usually cassandra
needs some schema associated with it and
it hasn't acted in the past like a graph
or a document database but the document
api allows you to just persist json like
nested json and it creates a table
indexes for you and all that kind of
stuff and so
we can add indexes to our graphql stuff
but
the document interfaces allows you to do
that
and does that for you so here's let me
jump back here so change the location to
the key space url on the graphql
playground which we already know is
netflix key space
and then we can go back into our
environment oops
i don't want to have that i want to go
here okay
so that's my astra endpoint and this
auto saves which is handy so what else
do i need to do here
so let's double check that i'm in the
right place
and this will say are you sure you
wanted to allow this sure
okay so i am in dramatron no worries
there oh dramas
okay and then i
install the netlify cli
in this environment
this is all
downloading the world so to speak
luckily data's not on lockdown so i can
download it from all sorts of places and
don't have to worry about it too much
that's all done
and then
i got all this information and
did not leave the curly braces oh yeah
well i've already done all that
so once i've done that let me make sure
that i did that correctly i have my
environment here
perfect
and then i'll go on here and then i will
npm install to kind of build this all up
and then we'll launch the application
and that's basically i mean this is just
a normal netlify thing
um
so we'll we'll launch it in the
environment in netlify
so it's kind of just spinning up a dev
so netlify dab basically
starts a local dev environment you can
do this on your machine as well and then
it spins it up on the local host and so
it says okay i got my netflix account
and this
you can see
based on the very simple interface that
we have in here
allows you to have they have all the
components in here we have the nav bar
and all that
if we can go into a new browser tab like
click on this
and you can see it in here
so aliens
watch this as a kid it scared me quite a
bit
with ripley and newt
and everybody
so you have all these different genres
and then on it autoplays
the mp4 that
gives you a little bit of a
blurb about what it is
and go to the
movies and this kind of just gives you
an idea of how you can
make this all work and these are the the
imgr
cdn type of data files that were out
there
um that we talked about earlier
and so if we re refresh this page it
might be a different inception oh i
think it
this is still aliens but it's got the
the wrong
[Music]
it's just a data thing um
anyway
so
this is all seems to be working okay
so that's in our dev environment
we can also
log in to netlify
and
have that go to production
so let's quit out of that
oops
and i'll log in there
and the login needs to go to a new
window this simple browser doesn't
really
doesn't really help with that
so i'll authorize this
i'll log in there because i'm already
logged in to netlify
and then i will link it
let me go on here and again
it doesn't like that any either
oh no this says do you how do you want
to link this
you want to do yeah let's just do the
remote origin of that
that says
sounds good let's do this thing
and then i will
take the
env file and upload it to netlify
so if i do that in here
i will
import the environment variables that i
put in this environment file
it's kind of handy
and then i will deploy it to production
and netlify
in my little free environment that i
have so i'll build it first
making the product production build so
this is taking it from dev all the way
up through to production
and then
i'll run
deploy dash dash prod
to just make it work
so this is where it is and then there's
the netlify cli command to open up the
site
so let's do that and i think it'll just
do it in here and then we can put it
into this window then it'll go to so
this is just the simple
uh
interface here so
there's terminator 2
also scared me as a kid
there's that guy with a sword and
it was all trippy when i was a kid
okay
so
we have the same interface and it's been
deployed in the netlify app environment
with a url that i kind of i did the kind
of the the basic url there
um
so there it is
it's all
put together hopefully you've been able
to do this as well
you've deployed everything to netlify
and so from start to finish this isn't
really too bad
we had some pre-baked goods so to speak
astra is pretty handy to have this i
mean there's other databases out there
that are cloud hosted um you know
dynamodb cosmos uh but i think
the one of the nice things here is that
this is a cloud agnostic thing so that
you can run it whatever cloud you want
to
as well as having these apis that are
pretty nice to have as a
native interface into your database so
you it's a first-class citizen so um
you can
you can do essentially what netflix does
you can create your own streaming
service just to compete with stan and so
you can host like the castle or whatever
if you want to you know
be your own ideas man so to speak
um
i just watched that movie uh
pretty ridiculously funny but um and we
also have so you have the databases and
we also have a managed pulsar in here
um
[Music]
which allows you to uh
do things like you can cdc
from your uh database into other
services like elastic or whatever um
that's
that's uh kind of a nice feature to have
as well so
hopefully this has been helpful for you
today
[Music]
let's see
is there any other questions that people
have i know this looks a little bit
trippy in the interface but let me jump
out of the presentation mode
well let me let me finalize what we have
in here
and and just show you how this all comes
together
so we have this graphql this is kind of
a replay of what we've done we have this
graphql layer
and then what we did just to kind of
recap we deployed that to we created the
instance and then we have a token we
created the graphql in here as a native
native interface
into the database and then we have
netlify
which
does its thing to push to its kind of
cdn
through their to their system
and then git pod is the one that
takes everything
in an environment an online dev
environment it edit like you can edit
the code set it up and run it locally
with the netlify dev
and then it pushes we linked and
pushed that environment up to the
netlify
site manager
and so this is a serverless
infrastructure up here and this is a
serverless infrastructure down here and
so you know
everything's serverless now i mean
obviously there's servers running in the
background but
it makes it nice from a billing
perspective
so you just pay for what you what you
use
and you get the nice emoji smiley face
the other nice thing about astra the
database in a serverless form is that it
it it elastically scales with you we've
tested from you know a few thousand
requests per second to you know 20
million requests per second and it's
i think it's a p99 latency of about 20
milliseconds which is actually really
good and it and
the the serverless nature of it means
that you can scale
in seconds and so if you have a bursty
event like you know you're opening up
vaccinations to a new site or if you
have an event like this
you can scale very easily and very
quickly
so that you never have any sort of
downtime and you just pay for you don't
have to worry about like
pre-provisioning the ops
it it provisions that out because you're
paying for the throughput you don't have
to worry about that at all and then
it'll scale back down so you're not
really paying for persistent
infrastructure that's the nice thing
about this serverless system
and it's all secure through the like the
the keys that are for your organization
and that sort of thing
so
we did the deploy to prod
and there's a bonus there
um in the repo if you want to do that
um
and then again i just want to to call
your attention to
our data stacks
cassandra day to kind of give you a
hands-on
workshop
for a full day
it's free
and
it also has a call for papers
if you want to build some sort of demo
or
do something like that we'd love to have
you involved
um
and
just want to
invite you out to that
thank you again for for your time today
um
and
i hope this isn't too trippy and i hope
that that gives you some ideas to kind
of
uh
apply your your graphql
expertise in a in a new way
and
give you
give you some new thoughts in terms of
cassandra i know cassandra traditionally
hasn't been as developer friendly but i
think we're making strides with the
um
with astra with stargate and and with
that sort of thing and so you leave the
management of of astra
uh cassandra to us
and you leave the api gateways to us and
you just focus on developing whatever
applications that you might dream up or
or for your organization you know we
work with a number of banks here in
sydney telcos and and others
and also a lot of startups
um
netflix is just one of several
that use it for
like
streaming a streaming gateway and other
things
so
thank you very much uh
like to also call your attention to we
have a uh
a cloud native database and a
self-managed form and we call that case
sandra
so if you're looking for a way to deploy
this
style of cloud native database um we're
working on open sourcing the ways that
we do that in astra but um the cloud
native uh style
of database that's out there now in a
self-managed form is under the banner of
case sandra so
io
that's the the website to get to
using
cassandra in a cloud-native way
so if there's nothing else i think
that's everything for today uh hope that
hope that you've enjoyed
building this and
and look forward to seeing so hopefully
some of you at the cassandra day next
month